hi guys today I'm playing another
minisode of to the moon for you
I played the fast minisode if you missed
that go and click somewhere around here
maybe here click here yes here to see
the first minisode and then come back
and watch this one because apparently
this one has a lot more to do with the
actual story up to the moon so I'm very
excited to play it it's like three red
games again just like everything else
yeah let's play this well Alisa sighs
leave oh yeah so in the last episode
it's finished width or episode minisode
it finished with your thumbs checking
the tomatoes at the windows were
obviously starting from where we left
off guess what
save the teen up for after the break
we've ought to leave or just get that
external fruit collector set up we've
altered what what is that what kind of
language is this perfectly cool in the
snowing kept fresh to get this it's like
we're inside and the fridge it outside
mind blown
precisely sure good job I knew it I
wonder if the others are leaving early
now the roads cleared okay so they're
going now yeah might as well
I don't believe the calls pushed our
Christmas party this late oh no not a
late Christmas party are you heading
home ready to yeah why not she's not
very happy she I'm spending the evening
sirs family they didn't live far from
him with their little brat her I love
her he just comes out with these things
ah what's I've missed you yeah well that
little brat still got me a better gift
than yours
Oh bad friend hey at least I tried to
get my partner something something from
my partner and like a certain somebody
guess again
oh she was saving it
what is that it's an ambient sound maker
it cycles through soothing background so
it sounds like beaches or a course of
crickets
why would once want that check this out
it sounds like something I could do on
my phone true
oh yeah well this also allows for
recording a custom track of your own to
loop back just press rec and you can
make your own custom ambience custom
ambient sound - right - what is wrong
with my voice today I can't can't speak
apparently again so I was thinking that
I didn't want to say I guess neither of
us a particular gift give its hey I'll
still take it I'll probably record Rob
getting scolds to the custom track and
for a suture or whatnot yeah yeah anyway
how about you you got plans well oh oh
come here you stud what what wait I
probably said that in the wrong voice
it's probably supposed to be a sexy
voice Oh Oh have you been getting
handsome a rather day my dear I am so
Bertha brick and you are still steamy
like a hot bun
when I looked into your eyes it's been a
gentle wave well you are my friend oh my
god are you not it'll mix and water it's
not my back I just pick you up and
awkward hey hey oh my gosh can you
imagine oh no way
it's snowing outside yeah and the
crickets are playing now okay I think
that's enough for today yeah definitely
I'm heading out you do that oh well
let's go outside
hopefully we don't run into those old
canoodling people again that was a bit
strange
hello who is this hello
mmm interesting what do you want today
shall we
you wanna go out date just like Mickey
Mouse's hand doesn't go in there all
right
the feet go to you to go to the lounge
that's the Christmas party see if
everyone's left I remember that party it
was quite fun actually
oh look I know there are some people
left I'm so relieved that we're finally
getting a break I'll be nice to spend
some time with the family have a good
evening Lisa you deserve it
everyone does especially well as in
timer to be honest I'm worried about
them yeah they do work way too hard for
their age honestly I don't think I'd be
able to do theirs when the time comes
what oh oh
that's morbid no man I know Herman cops
caught our night covered by contracts
and all but I still feel kind of uneasy
they're our competitor after all yeah
but I guess that's one of the few ways
to get some reliable time off in this
job besides what we're doing the same
thing for them so they better do a good
job
I'm lost I don't know what they're doing
you mad anyway I think you want to go
don't you okay that's okay let's go to
lobby Shh cuz you wanna go see your
family
oh hello Eva no it's okay you don't need
to explain no less you don't understand
you see sometimes when a man loves a
woman very much of [ __ ] you my stuff's
back at the office oh bloody hell fine I
want everywhere else first
hey Eva
Hey oops my bad
you can just press the button again I
wanna be exactly where are you weird kid
okay
you're right Roxy oh hi Ava
yep I'm just waiting on Bob he's right
under maintenance the weight carpooling
hey Raj hey Jose don't burn it anyway
what's up - uh not much just hurry home
to have dinner with my sister's family
we've always had our Christmas dinner
together and they've been waiting wow
how nice of them the techies surely
wouldn't have stuck around if it'd been
me
I bet did she call you fat you got any
plans tonight well I gotta meet uh
persons folks later folks
but first I got a date with a good old
couch and some ice cream that sounds
like a perfect date I'm gonna grab a
whole bucket and scoop it and then I'm
gonna spoon it sounds like a lovely time
yep yep yes it does
okay let's grab your stuff dear diary
today I shoot not again
the door was open to better look at wave
good oh yeah cuz when we played last
time what's his face read her diary I
remember that
she's a keep better care of it might get
your bag and oh shoot oh oh is it Rob I
just got ready but now I've got two
winters without her stuff you ready yet
almost how's the situation outside
looking all cleared up probably because
of cold dude it's about time
why were they so angry again can't
remember oh I'm sure I'll find out Shh
go to the lobby
Shh now we can go heading off you're
still here yep
and I'm staying here tonight wait what I
don't have a home what can I say it's
just kind of hard working Samaritan that
I am she can't wait to get to her ice
cream Neil Baum its Robert
anyway never good evening your sisters
blades well I know this wait
random stuff okay you're been going to
stay here on the only break we've gotten
in months
yep all this mansion to myself yes
please
all right then she's not gonna go she's
gonna stay hey if you want mm-hmm never
mind
oh she wanted to stay with him
their little car Eva hey sis I'm heading
over now see you in a bit yeah you
imagine how freaky that would be that
whole office to yourself
I'd hire a massive ball pit still fun on
your own back yep there is he's staying
there all by himself but isn't this like
Christmas for you guys yeah well I don't
know what he's up to
hun you shouldn't mind him over to
dinner what don't be absurd you're
thinking too much into it silly I don't
mean for anything else just like how
workers sake you know I know the guy
he's not one to come over anyways
get the dishes started for you I'll be
there in just a bit okay hon I'll see
you then
no you can't go Eva what was that you
okay huh what was that are you daya
it's his South Eva can you hear me yeah
I'll be there in just a bit
okay huh see you then what that was
weird and confusing
come on 30th time's a charm so he's
trying to make the dream thing that we
saw in Edgewater me and the moment of
truth circuit abnormality detected main
power disconnected what how does that
even I better get down to the basement
and reset the switch before someone sees
Oh could be dark places at least the
elevators and auxiliary power I could
reach the basement from the lobby
creepy
go to the lobby a oh that's a pretty
cool way to get down to the basement
since patching to see a door but no I'm
moving platform okay for a tech facility
the power supply sure isn't reliable
access profile loaded doctor new watts
access time nineteen forty seven or ten
to eight all right let's get you booted
up first our state is charging for we
ignition and now let's see what happened
here it's almost as if someone's in a
manual shutoff purging operation record
I don't understand this can't be right
there must be a glitch in the system
why what happened who's there yeah
defend yourself with a broom what the
hell so I've got this badass weapon in
the whole entire world nothing can stop
me now who it's gonna be Eva though
isn't it but the door was locked
okay but she probably has key I'm gonna
hit Eva with a broom hey you up power
restored huh how's the towel Han that
helps Thanks what's wrong with you and
nobody would gonna work my sister like
that sheshe wasn't accident all right
your face was an accident
best to come back you just go around the
office ringing through swinging a broom
around all day look I was in beast mode
and she just suddenly appeared on my
turf it's not my fault I was born with
such crazily fast reflexes
why did you guys come over anyway you're
one to ask staying all alone that offers
on your holiday off who does that
it was her idea Don invited is I ain't
having no part of my sister's up by
himself on on on a night like this I
wasn't so you just shop and listen Irene
like yo she's cool Eva cordons and old
friends and we're all gonna have a nice
dinner together
and you're gonna enjoy every moment of
it wow you kind of remind me of someone
that I know either hey kitty came out
open the box dad can I go on ask Eva and
asked what door has gotten Eva it's not
ours
hey kid dude what's in the box what's in
the box we don't actually know what yeah
come to think of it those exact same
boxes for here last year do well can we
open up no I don't think I don't know
whose they are so they just sit here yep
that's what they do
I don't get it
me neither oh hi
and now what there that huh it's
actually not that bad
what was that why is he still here
ooh what am I supposed to go I can't go
anyway I came to talk to me hey sorry
about your face don't talk to me
it was a soft under the broom sheesh
come to think of it I should have been
charging you for facial massage go away
I thought so that guy man Neal we only
just got here and you've already got
Tracy all worked up workplace hazard
can't help it yeah it's a dangerous
place don't even want to imagine what
you do with them up our insurance policy
forbids me from handling one
so then decorations I don't know man
I don't know okay so it looks like I
need to go elsewhere you're going to Shh
hello oh hi yeah I thought you went home
with your ice cream yeah I thought so
too
but I was as I was happily pigging out
on the couch Eva calls and asked for a
pickup what but she's already here hello
what the hi Uncle Neil and that's I'm
you two came by you called me a poopoo
face that was Tommy he's mean wow that
kids growing up to be a lizard sorry
Lily it's been a while Neil yep even a
strategy guys right all your loving home
huh oh it's nice to come and visit the
kids were getting bored at home anyway
wow wow wow let's go inside we could be
missing dinner by now oh yes I should go
say hi okay
yeah that's what I thought
escaping too many people too much
socialization that's even a word
then she's holding the dark thing it's
not done what is it Eva what is that
beaver
it's a platf light or as a platypus the
platypus
it's not mine but Mars edits I'm I'm its
caretaker now I protect it from all evil
can I see it are you evil not really
okay you can up up up five minutes
hey are you a real doctor what do you
mean like do you do surgeries and stuff
no then you're not a real doctor
do you listen to dr. Dre no me neither
but Neil says Dre's not a real doctor
and he still got mad respect so back off
funny kids like oh hey Jamie what are
you doing with that stuffed animal don't
wuss out on me son hey Jack's dad it's
just clap clap yeah dad chill hugs your
eyes can play with stuffed animals too
Freddie you're better I'll live you know
ever heard you got to come over more I
rarely see you anymore well winter tends
to be our busiest season hopefully we'll
get more of a break soon don't work too
hard now you know what I'm always here
if you need me that's nice why do you
have to go all the way around okay fine
hey thanks for helping me drive Liddy
and the kids over
no biggie as long as you hold up your
side of the deal what was the side yeah
I got it I'm serious two buckets of ice
cream no chip outs okay Ben and Jerry's
yes
yeah Roxy I will like we're talking
jumbo size here with a capital J
and when I say buckets I mean [ __ ] kids
and then I want to use them as for
cycling bins when I'm done with them
yeah where do you shop thanks for having
us over Eva
hey I just hope I wasn't interrupting
anything not at all it's nice to take
those two Rascals out Johnny's house has
a beautiful view but it's a bit remote
for the kids account pattern can't power
they do get to play outside nicely but I
keep fearing the trip and roll down the
cliff that would be bad
no that would be superb sub-optimal
that's the one suboptimal jingle bells
Batman smells hey is anyone seen you run
into him in the hall but he didn't throw
us back in seems like he went back down
for some reason let's check it out they
say you were met down here did he I
thought you weren't that's the office
scene um why is he outside what's he
doing hello who is calling
who is this son son he has a son is that
you Neil
oh why is this dad why aren't you
talking to them was it something I did
no it's not them then why why is she why
did you come back I told you already it
was my sister's idea you could have
stopped her look thanks for coming back
and bring the folks in all but just
don't do something like that again
do what why are you going home I've got
things to work on what the hell is wrong
with you good call Eva I don't know
what's going on there but for pinapples
sake loosen up these people came all the
way out here to spend the evening with
you when was the last time you even had
dinner with other people my sister
brought her family to keep the company
even lily and the kids came you still
remember them right you even made that
stupid game based on that case what are
you gonna do when you go home do we a
frozen pizza by yourself
just give yourself a break for tonight
sheesh anyway I'm not gonna just stand
out here in the code tossing Brides at
you you do what you want I'm heading
inside just know there's a chair
upstairs for you whether you're coming
or not
you go Eva I'll turn around what
doors
Oh
that was short
ah look at them they're all eating
Christmas dinner it makes me want want
to have Christmas again you've got to
wait so long for Christmas now it's just
been Christmas there she's like oh my
gosh what's happening
with the platypus
what are you recording
laughter happiness
my favorite games community a message oh
yes as soon as you read this and help
out I've already done it but yes the the
art worker is in hospital
well well what that wasn't so bad was it
everybody had a good time yeah I guess
say hey can you guys give me a lift
Nilsa wassouf she was dreaming where is
she hey can you guys give me a lift
Nelson is the company car tonight I'm
confused
dad she gave me shivers what sure hon
let's get you home
wait what
that's not fair that's not fair at all
no
so she was dreaming and that was back in
her past
and that would explain why she saw
herself sounding in front of her car
that was really good as normal it was
very short maybe I missed some stuff but
it was cute and lovely just like every
other free bread game and now he's going
back on to the second episode so he's
gonna make his longer game and that was
the one that you saw at the end of a bad
story so I'm very excited for that
anyway give this video a thumbs up if
you enjoyed I really appreciate it and
have a lovely day out evening bye good
bird no no you're gonna give it back now